and
[Music]
um it's really interesting what he told
you uh especially because like the first
season was sick yeah and the second
season is just like all about farming
for some reason
and then you're like out farming it's
more it's the majority of them but it's
not about just farming what's actually
really interesting about that is in that
in in the second season there are very
clear uh class Dynamics at play like
class in the marxian sense yeah where
the uh indentured serve uh the
indentured servants the slaves right
um are are undermined by The Peasants
yeah yeah even though the owner of the
farm is very nice to the slaves in
comparison to how mean he could be
technically and this might change but
this is as far as I've seen so far in
the second season and I I didn't read it
so I don't know but
um there there's a moment where uh you
know thorphin is talking to the other
slave
and the other slave is like these
peasants they're they're bullying us but
they don't realize that like they're in
the same position they own no land but
the reason why they're doing this to us
the reason why they're like stealing our
food or undermining us or not giving us
horses and whatnot is because it makes
them feel like they have some kind of
lordship over us right yeah yeah and
that is at the heart of literal like um
that's the that's the class position
that many people have uh it's very
important in like the civil rights
movement in America is very important in
like uh you know uh the the
Reconstruction Era politics in America
in the aftermath of the abolition of
slavery where like uh you know newly
free newly freed uh black people
um started recognizing that they had
exactly the same class position as the
Layman the people that were Wade slaves
right right
um and and um that that wage slaves yeah
it's like what it's considered I think
like originally in the Republican party
uh In America which is now very
different Republican party started off
with uh wanting to abolish slavery
um you know Shadow slavery in the South
and Wade slavery in the North like that
was their Credo right
um so uh but basically no I mean I don't
even heard that online people did saying
derogatory those people who just work
normal jobs no I mean McDonald's you're
a wage slave well yeah they they you use
it as a as a derogatory term but
um but yeah that's it's that's at the
heart of like class politics so there's
no way that dude wrote that on accident
no no for sure
is very I try to keep very anime but
does go ahead tell me it's not political
super political yeah I mean okay so when
you say it's political do you think
there is a do you think it's just
exploring political ideas or do you
think there's uh are you saying that
there's an agenda that he's trying to
like portray in this story I don't think
it's nefarious I think that people have
World Views yeah that they inevitably
bake into their art you know what I mean
and I think like his world view from
what you've told me especially like he's
like a pacifist humanitarian yeah yeah I
mean
um he I mean for once I actually have a
source because I talk to the [__]
I'm not making this a [__] up yeah no he
uh he said the reason he wanted to make
villain Saga is that he wanted he
thought it won he thought it was an
interesting interesting idea for a story
to agree have a story about violence and
promoting how you know bad war and
violence is and setting that in the
Viking era why did he make it so cool
um that's the problem season one is so
bad at yeah yeah and then season two
feels like such a departure yeah in a
sense of like when is that gonna happen
yeah every time I see that log throwing
Guy what's the big one oh four kills
every time I see him I'm like oh thank
God all right let's get let's get some
violence in here
yeah and like he was he he told me that
he was very very worried going into like
part two uh because in order to
establish the you know this message he
needed to establish a world where it was
violence was glorified and then what he
wanted to do was establish his world of
glorified violence and kind of break
down why you know why that's bad and why
would you see another angle to that and
uh one of his biggest worries is that he
did a bit of a bit too good of a job
with that because everyone uh because
everyone really really loved the first
part yeah just definitely went over a
lot of people's hands yeah yeah yeah I
thought the message was like violence is
sick that's what I thought
it's okay if you're Welsh yeah yeah yeah
as long as you're a viking it's okay
yeah yeah you love that he's like the
best Welsh representation ever it's the
only representation we got in here yeah
yeah exactly so sick you know you know
what he called you know what he called
askalad you said cute right I said cute
he said he said he said ask lad was my
favorite character even though it was
like very hard for him to pick yeah and
I was like oh why'd you like ask a lot
and he was like oh Kawaii and I was like
what I mean he's cute he's a cute
[__] he is I see it yeah but
yeah I mean like I I asked him where did
you get your inspiration for your story
are you trying to say anything you know
are you trying to how did you get the
ideas for what you wanted to portray in
this story
um and he basically just said I just I
sometimes I just have thoughts and ideas
and emotions that I want to convey
through the story and I find the best
way uh with characters and with the
world to basically convey my my thoughts
and emotions and so I don't know how
deeply he thinks into the political
ideas but I think at the core he has
these emotions
um that he wants to put on the page and
so um oh yeah finds the best way to get
the moving parts to like portray that I
don't even think he's like ideologically
marks is there anything like that I just
uh I think it's like very human to
recognize that Injustice yeah yeah so so
it totally still makes sense but I mean
it's at the heart of that kind of
politics right yeah I think I think
talking to him he is a very human like
article he tries to tell very human
stories and he tries to put that in
everything he does well I would argue
that's what makes some of the best
stories in monger and Anime right it's
like when you're trying to show that
like very Human Side of like you know
through emotions and you know uh
physical violence and stuff like that it
was like oh okay it's not just like a
bunch of people killing each other
there's like some message there and you
know depending on who you ask you know
they get the message more than others
obviously Hassan has like [__] nailed
it but I love it yeah yeah but like I
think it's I think some of the best
authors especially in the manga world
are able to kind of you know try and
show both sides of aware it's like you
can think of it as shallowly as possible
or as deeply as possible and it's still
just as enjoyable I want more historical
manga anime I feel like it's hard though
because I know it's hard but it's so
cool when they do it the amount of
research that he has to go through just
to write like a single chapter is
[__] insane yeah like he has he has
to do so much research because what what
uh how many how many how much Viking
media do we get here in Japan like
nothing that's nothing that's what's
fascinating about it because it's like
such a unique time period uh like Dane
law and the invasion of like England is
is so cool and there's a lot of content
in the western world yeah but it it
pairs very nicely with like the last
Kingdom and and other kinds of like
Western live action like docu dramas you
know what I mean like fictionalized
depictions of what happened so it works
really well with that yeah and I think I
think what's most impressive is that
he's done his research and he's taken
like real historical accounts like you
know Thor Thor Kell
um thorofin they were all like real
actually I don't know if Thor's was a
real character but Thor uh thorofin was
definitely a real person in history
right yeah and so you he takes these
accounts of real things that happen in
histories uh and he's kind of like
filled in the blanks with his own
imagination or even his even dorvin's
Granddad or I guess is technically is
that his grandfather like the guy who
went to oh lethal request yeah yeah yeah
that's that's really personal really
awesome yeah yeah the first person who
like actually found well found America
yeah the continent I know that yeah yeah
uncredited if you're watching the anime
and loving every second yeah like damn
yeah if you want to get spoilers just
read the Wikipedia page
I read all the manga was at the time
extended edition of the manga yeah it's
like that extra law that's the light
novel that's what I love about
historical shows is that if you want
more you can just go to Wikipedia like
you can you can look in and around where
they tell the story gotta be like oh
this is fun yeah like I don't want to
wait for the manga to come out I'm just
going to read them
I realize why they stopped at a certain
point because it just the stories often
just go downhill because history can't
always be interesting or the person's
weird yeah they become really strange or
do weird [__] up stuff yeah yeah well
you know sometimes they still take weird
characters like in Jojo and uh present
them in a Shining Light
Nazi
that was like I was not expecting that
one I was watching because I'm like I'm
like wow this like new anime I got into
is like so sick I'm like burning through
the episodes and then bam I'm like what
did I just see a swastika what the [__]
like and then and then I'm like okay
like this is clearly a villain right and
then and then at the end it's like oh no
he's like a good guy
and you think like oh he's gonna like be
a Nazi killer right and then he's like
no he died in Germany in World War II
fighting fighting for the Nazis
like they put that in there I was like I
think I wiped that from him yeah I
completely forgot about that that's like
such an insane thing that they put in
there that you just don't have to put in
but we did it anyway and I was like wow
well this is this is untainted by
Western liberal hegemonic attitudes I'll
tell you that okay wait I go to awesome
you've have you finished part six no oh
I wanted them to get to it yeah yeah I'm
gonna I'm gonna message you when you
finish politics because there is is a
point in part six where they tackle the
topic of racism in America
oh that's my favorite yeah
and I I want to hear your takes on that
oh that's so sick I love that yeah it's
near the end of part six so yeah we'll
we'll continue this conversation I love
yeah I love when like you know Japanese
people are like yeah let's let's cover
American races yeah like out of nowhere
no I'm fascinated by like the
perspective of someone that's like super
far removed from you know like the
actual history or the culture like
there's not it's not like there's a lot
of black people in Japan you know what I
mean yeah I grew up in Turkey not a lot
of like uh afro Turks in turkey that's
not like a real thing it's like very
marginal very small amount yeah so uh
you know I was fascinated by by Black
Culture in America so I I kind of get
how that works on this part of the world
because like a lot of American culture
is Black Culture for the most part it's
just like so a lot of the popular
depictions of American culture is
literally uh usually Black Culture yeah
um and and so I I love I love seeing
other people also go through that
speaking of black culture and Anime
actually one of the reasons why one of
the reasons why I love Samurai shampoo
is because like it kind of merges like
oh yeah it starts yeah K-pop stuff yeah
it's like it's so weird that you know
before Samurai Champloo you know the
idea of merging samurais with hip-hop
was just so out of left field and now it
just like it's like the perfect glove
that fits yeah like how would how did no
one think of this before as well yeah
why does it work so well I still have no
idea there were some other ones too have
you guys ever seen Afro Samurai yeah
hell yeah
that's sick I would even go so far say
like Boondocks is also like weirdly
drawn exactly in the anime style I don't
know why but like it's one of my
favorite I would say animes I guess I
don't know yeah it's like anime inspired
cartoon yeah yeah I think one of the
co-creators LaShawn Thomas is like he's
a huge anime yeah to the point where
he's made some some of his own original
animation yeah as well so it's no
surprise that it was probably heavily
inspired yeah no it's it's that that I I
love because like I when I was in Turkey
I was like watching the [__] out of that
I love Aaron Magruder he's brilliant
really really clever
um and you know so there is this like
very cool merger of two cultures uh in
that respect yeah absolutely I mean it's
kind of like like as like you said a lot
of there's a lot of fascination with you
know the Western World and especially
the American culture here in Japan and
you know oh I've seen it oh yeah yeah
not even in anime man in just everything
but I'm like that too I'm a Marabou so
like yeah so like that's what that
that's what I was I think they're called
Wester booze yeah yeah the British one's
called tiaboo
yeah who the [__] is booing the British
culture
the British vlogger Invasion yeah like
literally just 10 years ago on the
internet being British was like the
coolest thing ever okay I got on it I
guess I erased after my memory because
like thank God
about the Tuesday era for a second yeah
there was like there was an era of
British uh culture where every American
thought he was cool you know because
because of Mostly because of like Harry
Potter actually yeah back when that was
yeah no Americans like a good chunk of
Americans still think like that's
England is Hogwarts yeah like they think
it's real you know yeah it's just an
entire country ruin my fantasy I mean a
lot of Japanese people think that way as
well oh yeah yeah oh no I've been to
Harajuku I know I know what Japanese
people think America looks like right
now it's like they they were trying to
sell me like Yankee sweaters and [__]
I'm like no man I'm good